und zwar sind die beiden blöcke die ihr
seht die gleichen knöpfe
hallo ich meine liebe von und herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen folge der
minecraft heute am freitag und mir
wurden wieder viele cool effect
zugesendet ich habe mir fünf kilo
rausgesucht besonders wieder die letzten
finde ich ganz cool in wie habe ich
immer die letzten facts als die coolsten
aber ich würde einfach sagen viel spaß
beim video anfang an mit feck nummer
eins erste feld wurde mir zugesendet vom
dennis und zwar schreibt der hai luca
ich habe bemerkt wenn man in den fv da
ich spinne im staate david bemerkt wenn
man in den f5 schrägstrich person modus
mode mode modus schaltet und blog das
automatisch wieder aus dem fünften wurde
es in den first person modus also mal
ganz kurz ich hab hier so'n keine
konstruktion aufgebaut hier sein
redstone dinge und das geht hier da an
seinen pisten ich zeig euch das mal
einfach ganz kurz das ganze wird hier so
betrieben ich klicke drauf da geht
logge mich rein und medien heraus und
zwar mache ich das ganze jetzt mal
wieder züge in den app 5 modus und ich
sehe ihr seht meine linke hand ist nicht
einer tastatur meinen rechner betätigt
jetzt eben den die rechte maustaste und
jetzt seht ihr ich bin in den block drin
und wenn ich jetzt beispielsweise
einfach mal den boxer schlage seht ich
bin automatisch wieder in dem normalen
dem normalen first person modus und ihr
seht ich habe nicht er fünf glücklich
war die ganze zeit mit der hand ich
hatte sich an das zeigen die ganze der
hand an der mauer und das war feck
nummer eins das man wenn man in einem
blog drin fest packt das man dann
automatisch wieder den ansichts modus
wechselt von vogelperspektive zu erfährt
ihr wisst was ich meine
der zweite effekt wurde mir zugesendet
von maxi und zwar schreibt der man kann
zwar tintenfische anleihen aber das
bringt nichts man kann so hoch fliegen
will sie kommen nicht so wie bei kühlen
oder schwein und so weiter mit einem mit
lassen sich nicht mal wasser linken also
in eine richtung hin führen deshalb in
der maxi geschrieben ist was brauche ich
jetzt ein fachmann tintenfisch packen
hier alleine und ich kann wirklich zu
hoch fliegen wie ich will ihr seht da
ist der tintenfisch ganz unten am start
den juckt das nicht der fiktion noch
weiter weg um eine ganze weile hier ist
quasi führen muss ich kann ihn nicht
mehr durchs wasser durchziehen
das liegt doch nicht da nicht daran dass
die nati so gespannt habe sondern ich
habe hier auch einfach mal so ein paar
normale jetzt hier gefunden kann ich
einfach mal eine dran packen kann ich
nicht mit mir mitziehen er sieht schon
den yog das gar nicht der täter seine
entfernung und schwimmt wieder bilder
linie entlang allerdings kann man die
laut wikipedia also wenn laut diesem
minecraft wiki eintrag kann man die an
einen zaun fest machen das ganze kann
ich allerdings nicht beurteilen weil der
fake hat darum handelt das man wirklich
wenn ich mir irgendwie schweine oder so
ist natürlich komplett klar übrigens der
sieht es wieder ganz grün hätte das
direkt am wasser tempel und hier sind
die auf einer insel
also hier habt ihr schon mal den zehn am
start denn ich mir hier jetzt ein
schwein holen das einfach mal hinsetzen
und das anleihe kette dann seht ihr
schon das ganze schweiz liegt mit
mittelmaß oder wieder runter lassen und
so mit mir hin und herziehen bei einem
tintenfisch ist es allerdings der fall
dass die sich davon nicht beeindrucken
lassen und dann nichts passiert wenn ich
dann alleine ab der dritte effekt wurde
mir zugesendet von hadoop in place und
zwar schreibt er als ich gerade eine
bohrinsel gebaut habe keine ahnung warum
eine bohrinsel boots habe ich entdeckt
dass wenn man ein spinnennetz über einem
feuer platte weniger qualm vom feuer
ausgeht das ganze ja schon alles wieder
an zu brennen
hier jedenfalls nehme ich hier jetzt
beispielsweise mal in violett gefärbten
ton und takt dinge darüber ihr seht
schon die partikel gehen durch diesem
ton durch das liegt nicht an dem ton
block zu block neben ihr seht das ganze
geht ihr durch die erde durch oder geht
an der erde vorbei wenn ich allerdings
ein spinnennetz nehme wenn ich hier
irgendwie mal spinnen ja auch noch alles
an zu brennen wenn ich hier spinnennetze
drüber packe seht ihr schon wie partikel
bleiben in dem spinnennetz hängen da
dachte ich es liegt allgemein daran dass
partikel daran hängen bleiben aber wenn
zum beispiel regnet gehen die partikel
auch dadurch und soweit ein paar artikel
sachen aber hier bleiben die partikel
von der lava von dem von dem feuer in
dem in den spinden leben drin hängen und
kommen da quasi gar nicht durch also ist
eine ganz interessante sache danke an
die jugend place für den defekt und
jetzt kommt's fakten viele quattro
vierte effekt wurde mir zugesendet von
enders teil hd und zwar den ganzen text
geschrieben ich fasse soll man ganz gut
zusammen und zwar bis jetzt mal gefragt
wie kann ich ein schwert stadt dassow
rüberzuziehen auf den ersten platz
beispielsweise bekommen da muss ich
einfach auf das er daraufhin mit meiner
maus und dann die 1 drücken sie die
taste wo das schwert hin verschoben
werden soll jedenfalls wenn ich jetzt
hier auf diesem schwert drauf bin kann
ich jetzt halt einfach diese taste
drücken wie beispielsweise einer
einzelnen verschiebt sich das schwert
auf die eins und normalerweise ist es so
dass ich mit einem schwert im creative
mode keine blöcke zerstören kann und
zwar als es allerdings jetzt so ihr
wisst ich hab das vorhin einfach ohne
das schwer zu nehmen und rüberzuziehen
habe ich das einfach so mit der taste
gemacht
jetzt kann ich hier mit im creative
motorblöcke mit zerstören normalerweise
wenn ich so block ist der störe kommen
dann noch die partikel und alles möglich
aber so man hört keinen sound es kommen
keine partikel
das ganze gilt allerdings nicht wenn ich
beispielsweise schwert jetzt mal nehmen
und hier auf den vierten platz ihr und
jetzt hier darauf schlage dann geht es
nicht wenn ich allerdings hier auf dem
schwert raufen und druck jetzt die
sieben dann ist es eine siebte stelle
und dann kann ich keine blöcke zerstören
also ich verstehe es nicht wenn ich ich
hab das jetzt wieder auf den sechsten
platz belegt jetzt geht's wieder wenn
ich das jetzt laufen fünfte lege jetzt
geht's auch und irgendwie liegt am
siebten vielleicht am siebten wenn ich
auf siebten auf siebten geht's nicht
nicht dass auf dem vierten liga kommt
beim vierten geht auch beim dritten beim
dritten geht's wieder nicht also da gibt
es ein paar felder wo es wohl nicht geht
also ich hab jetzt nur für eins
rausgefunden dass es geht 5 geht hier
geht meine idee könnte selber
ausprobieren jedenfalls ist das ein
bisschen komisch glitschig verpackt
keine ahnung aber danke an enders teil
hd dass er das haus gefunden hat und das
perfekt nummero 4
die nächste sache bzw der letzte weg
wurde mir zugesendet von banane hd und
zwar das muss ich echt sagen mit der
beste fake der mini zugesendet wurde
weil es einfach eine extrem coole
optische täuschung ist beziehungsweise
seine optische illusion und zwar sind
die beiden blöcke die ihr seht die
gleichen blöcke ich zeige euch das ganze
jetzt noch mal wie das ganze halt so
gemacht mit mehr oder weniger und zwar
habe ich hier einen violett gefärbten
ton und hier einen magenta gefärbt
wir schauen jetzt einfach mal mit f3 in
welche richtung ich schauen zwar gucke
ich jetzt beispielsweise in die richtung
norden das heißt ich setze jetzt einfach
mal so einen magenta farben hin und dann
bin ich hier beispielsweise in den
westen gucke sitze ich immer einen
violetten hin da könnte ich hier
theoretisch auch mal so ein violetten
hinsetzt und dann der moment ich mal f3
weg detail unterscheiden sich wenn ich
das ganze allerdings mal andersrum mache
wenn ich beispielsweise hier einmal
gehen da hin setze hier einen violetten
und dann hier wieder so magenta seht ihr
das ist alles die gleiche farbe auch
wenn ich hier nochmal einen violetten
hinsetzt ich bleib mal die blöcke weg
ich stehe hier drin und es sind alles
die gleichen farben ich denke jeder wird
sagen das sind die gleichen leute wenn
ich allerdings hier mit der mittleren
maustaste darauf gehe habe ich einen
magenta gefärbten ton und wenn ich hier
mit der mittleren maustaste darauf gebe
ich ein violett gefärbten ton aber es
ist einfach die gleiche farbe sieht
genau gleich aus von oben sieht man das
ganze auch noch mal ganz gut und zwar
sieht man eigentlich ganz gut dass das
tier der magenta gefärbte ton ist und
hier der violett gefärbten allerdings
wenn man drinnen steht sieht das ganze
genau gleich aus wieder und das ist auf
jeden fall ne richtig richtig
interessant
rache ist eine richtig coole sache muss
ich sagen richtig toller effekt und wenn
ihr auch solche coolen facts kennt dann
schreibt sie mir doch einfach per mail
an konkreter gmail.com als morgen würde
ich sagen es euch gefallen hat würde ich
mich über einen daumen nach oben freuen
weil das zeigt mir dass euch die serie
gefällt und ihr weiter minecraft hacks
volt und alles mögliche geil findet und
ihr schokolade mögt und würde ich sagen
ich wünsche euch ein wunderschönes
wochenende